thank you
well and finally it all comes down to
this
the best picture and the nominees are as
good as it gets
James L Brooks Bridget Johnson Christie
SIA the producers
The Full Monty left of Pasolini producer
Good Will Hunting Lawrence Benga
producer
LA Confidential our motion Kristen
filters Hansen and Michael Nathan's
producing Titanic James Cameron John
Landau producer and the Oscar goes to
Titanic
one's third academy award of the evening
first for John Landau
oh so this morning I woke up and I
couldn't wait for the day to be over
now I don't want it to stop so I can't
act and I can't compose and I can't do
visual effects so I guess that's why I'm
producing but I have a lot of people
that I have to thank on behalf of both
Jim and myself I want to thank all the
nominees here this evening and all the
people that again they've already
thanked our incredible cast we would not
be here without you
my wife Julie my sons Jamie and Jody ray
Santini who is absolutely one of the
best people in this industry my mom and
dad Evie and Eli and now run through our
quick list of credits here Josh
McLaughlin malli Finn gig Rakowski Simon
crane Jimmy mural John Buckley Lloyd
Moriarty Charles Lee Martin Lang Roger
Barden Charlie Arneson Steve quale Kevin
Dillon oi Lance Julian Roger Hannah
Tommy Gordon les Collins Tony Gray's
mark Doug Fenton Harry heats Randy
Kirsten grant ale Sharon man and Anna
Roth this movie would not have been made
except for the conviction and belief of
Peter Chernin
bill mechanic Tom Zarek jim gianopolous
Tom Rothman Sanford panitch Vicky
Rosselini
Ted Galliano Mike Henderson Jim Barr
Darwinian Hillary Clark John Dalton
Sherry Lansing Rob Friedman John Goldwyn
Arthur Cohen Wayne Llewellyn Nancy
Gallagher plays note Oh Greg brilliant
John ranch Alison Jackson Maureen
Moebius and Steve Panama and we would
not be here without an incredible
screenwriter who wrote a great script
Jim Cameron okay I think John saw shine
too many times he thanked everybody out
and did everything I was going to say
and my eyes are still sort of doing
pinwheels from the last one so I just
want to say a couple of things we're
here tonight to celebrate the magic of
movies and I'm grateful every day to get
to be a part of that magic and a
practitioner in it and and I love it and
tonight has been such a great
celebration for us and it seems to
somehow Express this strange wave that's
happened with with Titanic where people
all over the world have have opened
their hearts to this movie and that's so
gratifying to all of us that worked on
it and we'll be forever forever grateful
to them the audience and I know a lot of
you are are watching
at home in the midst of all this
euphoria it's it's kind of hard for us
to remember that that this euphoria and
the success is for a film that's based
on a real event that happened where real
people died that shocked the world in in
1912 so I'd just like everybody to go
with me just for a second on something
here I'd like to I'd like to do a few
seconds of silence in remembrance of the
1500 men women and children who died
when the great ship died and the the
message of Titanic of course is that if
the great ship can sink the unthinkable
can happen the future is unknowable the
only thing that we truly own is today
life is precious so during these few
seconds I'd like you to also listen to
the beating of your own heart which is
the most precious thing in the world
join me please in a few seconds of
silence for Titanic
thank you very much that's about as much
as I'm sure Gil kids can stand alright
you've really made this a night to
remember in every way now let's go party
till dawn